Derek one of the themes of selfless is
shedding the old life when you look at
your own life
your career your accomplishments do you
ever feel like in some sense you're
almost living someone else's life hmm
wow that's a really good question so as
soon as do I feel like I'm shedding you
you know what I I do I feel like
everybody has another life and it's
really I call it the life of your dream
you know your dream has a reality that
most people kind of separate from their
president but I like to say that my
dream is my now yeah yeah so I in the
fact of shedding do I feel like I'm
someone else that's what you asked him
that's a real deep question I love to
chew on that well that's a good question
though yeah keeping with the shedding
theme mm-hmm let's say you had a little
brother or sister who was an aspiring
actor and maybe they'd been at it for a
few years and they wanted to shed that
struggling actor herself
mm-hm and develop a career like you've
had mm-hmm how would you advise them
well how would I advise friends our
sibling that has been struggling I would
say the bet the first coat and the first
law of shedding is empowering your inner
self you know that acting is a gift that
is not given by man so we just have to
really improve is your your inner image
opposed to your outer one during the
downtime for your career everybody has
peaks and valleys
do you ever mope about where things
should be hmm
or or what's your method with that with
my method for combating moping
my mother combating moping is basically
staying staying grounded and making sure
and remembering that I'm really the one
that's tearing my shift it's not a movie
is not people but I'm the one that's
controlling my joy and happiness
you